[Music]
good morning miss garcia
good morning sunshine i miss you i can
kiss you right now
[Music]
sunday curfew is now in effect
all unauthorized citizens must stay
indoors
tensions rise as we enter the 213th week
of lockdown
grim new reality emerges 23 has mutated
[Music]
a horrifying new development today it
confirms the virus attacks the brain
tissue
whoa whoa whoa whoa i'm immune
all infected americans are being forced
into quarantine camps
[Music]
sir what's going on
department of sanitation sarah talk to
me i think my neighbor has a fever
it'll be so much easier if you just open
the door
mrs grant you have visitors
do not open that door
beginning thermal scan three two
one anomaly detected
armed guards will be arriving in four to
six hours
you must not attempt to leave your home
or you will be shot on site
[Applause]
this is my best sense to you
i know you're in there
[Applause]
this is
we have to do things we don't want to
survive
i'm trying to save the one person left
in my life that matters to me
i can't help you what you're talking
about is illegal
[Applause]
[Music]
and remember stay safe sane and sanitize
[Music]
you